so congratulations on the film you are
leading this
you were awesome i love your character
how much fun did you have working on
this film
i had such a great time working on this
film there's so much
fun stuff that we got to do from the
stunts to
the music performances um
you know all the great costumes that i
got to wear
so yeah it was just an all-around great
time
so what was the stunt work like the
stunts were
super fun i've never done anything like
that
yeah ever um you know i have a dance
background
so that definitely lended itself to
the training that we had to do um but
yeah so there was
a lot of stunt training um and like
parkour stuff that we did with our
amazing
stunt coordinator and um
my character also plays the guitar she
rides a skateboard so i had a ton of
different
lessons and teachers kind of on a
constant like
rotating wow um but yeah it was fun to
be able to pick up some
some little party tricks along the way
yeah
i mean parkour is no joke i've tried
that one time and i like could never
get up like i was like done before
the first couple times we did it but
yeah it was really sort of
adding that physicality to um
through the the film and to our
characters i think it really helped
um the film a lot and also i think at
least for me
helped me get into character for sure
physical element yeah well obviously
your character
in this movie has a superpower so i want
to ask what superpower would you love to
have in your real life and that you
would use for good
yeah um i think
if i had a superpower it would be
um to fly always
so cool especially now where it's like
really not good to be at an airport or
anything just being able to go wherever
you want
whenever you want would be really nice i
also feel like
flying just would be a really crazy
experience
that would be great yeah who would want
to walk again if you can fly
um you know so many people fell in love
with you
in the show andy mack and now with this
show um
you know you're leading it how are you
loving kind of you know acting and where
your career is going
are you ready to take over hollywood yet
you know i'm trying to
but but yeah i think um
from andy mack to this it was really
difficult for me after andy mack
ended because that was such a story that
i felt very passionate about
and i connected with very closely and so
trying to find a project
coming off of that was very difficult
because i wanted i mean it's
you don't want to compare the things you
do but it's very hard
not to think well is it as good as this
is it better
you know and so finding something that i
just connected with as much and i felt
like was an important story to tell
like that was very important for me so
um so yeah i'm really excited for this
to be sort of my
next thing coming off of andy mac
because i do feel like it's a very
important story i think
it's an empowering story um which are
all things that
are really important to me and that i
look for in projects
yeah i don't want to make you know
meaningless content
that's just um there for the sake of
nothing you know and so so
so yeah i i am pretty happy with the
direction
my career is going and i hope it
continues down this path
yeah well so many people are excited of
course with you know mulan coming out
and now with secret society um you know
both have
asian american leads which is so
exciting are you finding that you're
seeing more
inclusivity and diversity in hollywood
do you feel like that's a main focus in
hollywood right now
i definitely think so i think right now
is such an
an exciting time to be in this industry
because things are changing
day to day you know everything's
evolving so much
um and you know with the black lives
matter movement and with all of these
things we're just realizing how
important it is
to be inclusive to be accepting
you know to to empower people because of
their differences not
not um not because they're like everyone
else you know
so i i definitely think um it's really
exciting to see how hollywood is moving
um in the direction of inclusivity and
and diversity and sort of being a part
of that wave in some small way
is definitely very exciting for me well
congratulations on the film you killed
it and it was just so much fun to watch
congrats
you